[Musique]
bienvenue c'est le dernier paris saclay
tv de la saison le dernier avant des
vacances bien méritées nous sommes dans
le quartier de moulon à gif-sur-yvette
un quartier en devenir qui se construit
à proximité immédiate de centrale
supélec et de l'école normale supérieure
de paris saclay sont prévues les
logements des résidences pour les
étudiants des écoles un parc ce parc et
des équipements publics
alors votre plateau il change il évolué
comment s'y retrouver
comment faire pour savoir où aller eh
bien les équipes de le paix à paris
saclay se sont mobilisés elles ont pris
le trop tôt bus
elles vous ont donné rendez-vous dans
des lieux stratégiques du territoire et
elles vous ont fourni un sésame une
carte ou retrouve toutes les
informations par exemple on y retrouve
l'adresse du tout nouveau musée de
l'école polytechnique x nous ouvre ses
portes et nous dévoile des trésors
accumulés depuis 224 en ouverte dans un
instant votre reportage enfin l'agenda
ce sera à la fin de cette émission
ce quartier de moulon est labellisé
innovant et écologique par la région ile
de france la région qui soutient trois
projets un groupe scolaire un projet de
lisières et ce parc de mon coup je me
trouve un parent qui a été conçu comme
un lieu de détente un lieu de rencontre
mais pas seulement puisque c'est
également un élément essentiel par sa
conception de la gestion hydrologique de
ce quartier un quartier qui accueillera
bientôt une nouvelle génération de
petits écoliers un groupe scolaire va
être construit ici il comptera vingt
classes de la maternelle à la primaire
il y aura aussi un centre de loisirs et
un gymnase
la rentrée est prévue pour 2019
[Musique]
il cède 1 d'un projet de groupe scolaire
école maternelle école élémentaire avec
une salle de sport un accueil
périscolaire une bibliothèque et donc la
responsabilité qu'on a dans ce projet
c'est de créer un lieu un lieu pour pour
la pédagogie et je dirais un lieu
bienveillant on a un contraste entre
l'intérieur très ludique et puis
l'extérieur plus sobre en extérieur qui
s'adresse à la ville en a mis l'accent
sur les transparences c'est un bâtiment
qui est très ouvert sur sur la place
notamment l'idée c'est de proposer un
lieu pour une pédagogie ouverte pour une
pédagogie en mouvement le chantier est
un chantier très court 17 mois et le
bâtiment est prévue pour une livraison
en 2019 donc septembre 2019
on aura vingt classes
alors
les premiers ambitions du parc était
faire une une liaison entre les
différents bâtiments qui sont tout
autour le parc il ya une diagonale qui
intégrer il ya une place centrale qui
est passé à côté de supélec
donc il ya en fait deux lieux un peu
différent un lieu qui a plus rien qui se
lier entre les bâtiments un lieu qui a
plu et présente qui est pour la détente
pour être dans la nature dans un
quartier qui est affaibli namik un
quartier de qui est payé par des
bâtiments scolaires étudiants et par des
logements pour le quartier un sujet
important pour le parc est aussi la
sécurité dans le quartier il ya un plan
hydraulique
ça veut dire qu'on veut éviter avec des
grands crus que il ya un problème
d'inondation pour ça le parc les espaces
publics jouent le rôle important et en
partie du parc dans leur concept pris
compte que c'est possible a demandé et
on peut dire que le petit parcours qui
croise le parc on peut voir comme une
rivière sèche qui devient inondées avec
les grands crus et qui trouve sa fin
dans les temps dans la boue du parc
[Musique]
le programme horizon est enclenchée
c'est le premier programme résidentiel
du campus urbain de paris saclay élite
ambitieux je vous donne quelques
chiffres mille logements 4 500 m² de
commerces le quartier de moulins se
construit ici à gif-sur-yvette c'est un
quartier traversé par un sillon paysage
et tout de suite les précisions de bruno
alloin coordinateur de ce programme et
jean mas architectes
[Musique]
l'ampleur de cette opération c'est quand
même une opération d'un peu plus de 1000
logements qui va s'étendre sur 500
mètres de long dans un axe est ouest
avec un sillon paysager qui traversera
donc du parc du moulon jusqu'à la plaine
des sports
l'ensemble des opérations ce sillon nous
l'avons voulu ouvert au public en cours
de journée est fermé la nuit pour la
tranquillité des futurs habitants
bien entendu dans cette opération nous
avons du logement social mais également
du logement locatif intermédiaire
c'est-à-dire que pour le parcours
résidentiel des futurs habitants il y à
des produits en accession bien entendu à
la propriété du logement locatif
intermédiaire et du logement social donc
un peu toutes les gammes de logements
cette opération sera livrée à l'été 2010
neuf dans sa première phase soit les
4500 m²
les équipements publics et les 800
premiers logements veux parler de défi
parce que
c'est un territoire évidemment du grand
paris mais une fois qu'on a dit ça ça
suffit pas parce que il était hors de
question évidemment de copier coller des
éléments parisiens et les amener ici à
saclay ici
un grand plateau il ya un territoire
absolument extraordinaire avec une très
grande profondeur un grand paysage et
donc par conséquent il fallait donner la
chance à chaque logement véritablement
de ne pas être dans un enfermement
alors qu'est ce qu'on a fait on a fait
des îlots ouvert avec ce qu'on appelle
un grand sion paysage est cueilli 100 m
il va du parc du moulon à la plaine des
sports
les enfants pourront jouer là parce que
ça sera sécurisé par des grilles mais le
matin plutôt que de prendre le trottoir
là où là les voitures là où lé bus là où
il ya du bruit on pourra traverser le
sillon et à les emmener ses enfants à
l'école dans un lieu un peu particulier
la deuxième qualité
si vous voulez c'est que je suis assis
dans mon séjour j'habite non pas sur rue
mais j'habite sur le sillon et bien le
soir de temps en temps en levant les
yeux peut voir le soleil couchant sur la
plaine des sports où le matin le soleil
se lever sur le parc du moulin et ça
c'est ce qu'on appelle des échappées
c'est à dire ne pas être enfermé mais
est ce vraiment dans un quartier ouvert
[Musique]
votre territoire se transporte alors
pour vous aider à vous y retrouver les
équipes de le paix à paris saclay sont
allés à votre rencontre grâce au proto
bus elles ont pu vous proposer un sésame
une carte on retrouve toutes les
informations nécessaires elles se sont
rendues dans des lieux stratégiques
comme ici courquin vasseur et c'est ici
justement que nous avons rencontré
prenant james le responsable du proto
[Musique]
nous sommes aujourd'hui avec le proto
bus pour un atelier des changes en
mobilité avec l'usagé de paris saclay
pour leur parler des nouveaux lieux et
des nouveaux services qui arrivent sur
le territoire
le proto but c'est un peu plus d'un an
et donc il existe pour pouvoir échanger
qu'ils agissent là où ils se trouvent
là où le travail là où j'étudie effet
aujourd'hui là où ils mangent tout
simplement on y court vasseur qu'un
nouvel espace public proche d'un
restaurant interentreprises et d'un
crous plus généralement on est au
carrefour de quatre écoles finalement
l'école polytechnique
lio js les saillies qui rêvait cette
année et l'as tu mets télécom qui arrive
en 2019
aujourd'hui on est là pour présenter
donc une carte nous aident card c'est
comme un dépliant avec deux faces d'un
côté pour présenter les mobilités les
sentiers les pistes cyclables et bien
sûr à une de bus et de l'autre côté les
nouveaux lieux à nouveau service soit
existe qui vont arriver sur les
logements le sport les loisirs la
culture
et puis tout ce qui est une ovation
euros narnia
aujourd'hui on s'est mis en face du
combat soeur parce que les commerces
vont commencer à arriver à partir de la
rentrée de septembre à décembre 2010 8,7
l'après midi c'était le deuxième atelier
des changes avec usage en mobilité et on
va recommencer à partir de la rentrée de
2018 pour continuer à être en proximité
à échanger à la fois sur quatre et
l'école polytechnique et puis sur le
quartier des moulins évidemment
[Musique]
nous vous l'avions annoncé l'école
polytechnique a ouvert son musée l'x
nous présente ces trésors des livres des
encyclopédies des instruments anciens
des costumes aussi une collection
prestigieuse accumulés depuis 224 en
voilà qui méritait bien une visite
guidée
[Musique]
la raison d'être de ce musée c'est
l'héritage de deux siècles d'histoire et
la plupart des instruments scientifiques
que l'on présente dans ce musée c'était
des instruments qui servait aux travaux
pratiques des élèves et ce sont aussi
des instruments qui provenaient des
laboratoires de l'école polytechnique
donc au départ ces instruments nous
n'avait pas vocation à être exposée dans
un musée il avait pour vocation de
servir à faire la science et donc du
fait de l'histoire ils se sont retrouvés
donc dans les collections de la
bibliothèque et ce qui manquait c'était
un lieu pour les exposer donc maintenant
le public a vraiment la possibilité de
venir découvrir ces instruments et au
travers de ces instruments découvrir
l'histoire de l'école polytechnique donc
qui existent je rappelle depuis 1794 et
dès l'origine de cette école il y avait
comme objectif de donner donc aux élèves
aussi bien des cours théoriques que des
cours pratiques donc dans des
laboratoires à la pointe des avancées
scientifiques de cette époque là vous
trouverez dans ce musée des instruments
et des documents qui sont antérieurs à
la création de l'école polytechnique
donc antérieurs à 1794
c'est assez curieux mais c'est pour une
raison qui est assez simple finalement
c'est que au moment où l'école est créée
en 1794 il faut donc réunir les
instruments qui seront localisés dans
les différents laboratoires et donc on
va aller chercher ces instruments dans
ce qu'on appelle les dépôts
révolutionnaire qui sont les dépôts où
l'on a réuni les différentes collections
qui proviennent des institutions royal
qui ont été supprimés par la révolution
qui
reviennent des collections privées de
nobles par exemple qui ont été
confisqués et donc dans ses collections
ses dépôts nationaux on trouve donc des
instruments et des ouvrages qui remonte
bien avant la révolution
le musée est gratuit et il est ouvert
donc tous les jours de la semaine du
lundi au vendredi de 9 heures à 17
heures sauf pendant les vacances
scolaires ou le musée donc est ouvert de
10h à 16h
m
et maintenant notre agenda alors ça sent
les vacances je n'ai qu'une seule date à
vous proposer le 11 juillet avec un
colloque qui nous explique comment la
transition énergétique passe aussi par
le paysage au programme des tables
rondes et témoignages il ateliers rendez
vous est pris de 9h à 16h 45 à la salle
toit de l'arche c'est à paris la défense
voilà c'est la fin de ce numéro je vous
souhaite un très très bel été on se
retrouve à la rentrée tout bronzé qu'il
espère d'ici là restez informé sur pbs
point fr et sur tv 78 merci
[Musique]